this week the nominees for the 2021
grammy awards were announced and we're
proud to say
17 artists nominated for 32 awards in 18
different categories have appeared on
this broadcast over the past
year or so most of them performing in
our saturday sessions
that includes our performers this
morning hi
the southern california sisters are up
for two awards including
album of the year for their latest
effort women in music
part three they'll perform in a moment
but first their conversation
with our very own anthony anthony mason
watch the heim sisters on video and
you'll find they're often
on the move i feel like i've walked all
of los angeles with you
i knew you were going to say it i knew
it
[Music]
nobody walks in l.a right
[Music]
[Music]
have been singing together forever it's
like since we could talk basically
typically do you guys see each other a
lot my morning routine is waking up
calling essie and danielle and then
going to either one of their houses it
depends
but we don't live together we don't live
together which is which people find
shocking
but this year the pandemic has kept them
apart
i mean i think in the beginning of the
pandemic was the first time that i
didn't see essendon every day since
birth how hard was that for you it was
really hard
we just didn't see each other for weeks
yeah until we shot the uh i know alone
music video that was the first time that
we saw each other
in real life
i know it wasn't intended this way
because it was written before the
pandemic but
i know alone seems like the perfect song
for this
moment in time more psychic i never get
calls from my friends whenever we put
out a song and that's the first time
they were like
i feel like you're seeing me for the
first time
the song from their latest album women
in music part
3 came out of their fatigue from being
on tour we all kind of fell into
just kind of like a collective down
downward spiral
it's all weird we're super fun to be
around
[Music]
now the sisters say they're desperate to
tour again
being a touring musician is like a weird
way of living right
it's also like the only thing that
brings me joy so like
it's a weird dichotomy it's really the
only thing that brings you joy
the only thing that brings me pure joy i
think it really is the only thing that
brings all of us your joy
this is turning into like now we're just
having like a you're like our therapist
now but you're going through i've been
accused of that before
you know we spent you know four years
just playing any show we could in la
four or five years
playing to two people playing with three
people so the fact that people
actually come to our shows to see us and
play all over the world is
still very mind-blowing yeah we're still
like you came to see us